Flohmärkte in Zeiten von Onlineshops wie
vintaged Kleiderkreisel oder ebay
kleinanzeigen ach so nee das heißt jetzt
nur noch Kleinanzeigen nein
dir Kleinanzeigen in diesem Zeiten wirkt
ein Flohmarkt irgendwie überholt und
anstrengend aber ein Vorteil sich schon
man wird seinen Kram einfach viel
schneller los und wie schnell das gehen
kann das haben wir schon am Anfang
gemerkt
gar nichts
nee das ist ähm
irgendwo habe ich mich auch über das
erste Interesse der potenziellen Kunden
gefreut aber es war super anstrengend da
ich noch nicht mal fertig mit dem
Auspacken war und schon verhandeln
musste über Dinge bei denen ich mir noch
nicht mal so richtig einen Preis
überlegt habe
ich weiß beste Voraussetzung für so ein
Flohmarkt
das hier
ist ein Adventskalender das hier äh das
ist ähm
ja es hat mir aber ein gutes Gefühl
gegeben dass das Interesse an unserem
Stand nicht abgeerbt ist und es ziemlich
gut weiter lief ich zeige euch jetzt mal
meinen stand das ist mein Stand von hier
sieht es irgendwie ganz toll aus dann
kannst du am besten dahin
wir können ja mal kurz vor der Kamera
darüber sprechen wie ich hier prozentual
beteiligt werde als Freundin Managerin
ne wir sind kleine
die mittlerweile viele von euch wissen
am Ende des Jahres ziehe ich in meine
erste
Eigentumswohnung und da möchte ich beim
Umzug sehr ungern viele Kartons
mitnehmen mit Zeug drin was eh in der
neuen Wohnung einfach wieder in
irgendeiner Schublade landet das heißt
verkaufen verkaufen verkaufen hier
drüben sind Klamotten da sind Klamotten
dort sind Klamotten und wir haben
Vanessas Schrank ich halte diesen
psychischen Druck von dem Handeln nicht
aus das ist mir zu viel ich kann das
nicht aber da kommt eine nerve für 1 €
für 1 € verkaufen wirklich aber ich
wollte den eigentlich auch umsonst dann
geben das waren so zwei Jungs aber ich
habe mir gedacht nee ihr müsst lernen
dass manche Dinge warum leben
am Anfang war dieses hauptsache weg
Motto ein bisschen zu groß geschrieben
bei uns denn wir haben von den
Nachbarständen schon den Hinweis
bekommen dass wir Klamotten teilweise
echt bisschen zu günstig rausgegeben
haben diese Kritik haben wir uns
natürlich zu Herzen genommen und unsere
Strategie ein klein wenig verändert ich
möchte ja auch Geld verdienen denn so
eine eigene Wohnung ist schon das
teuerste Projekt meines Lebens und da
heißt es schaffe schaffe Wohnung bauen
weiß weil es eigentlich Häusle bauen
heißt und aber wir bauen eine Wohnung
[Musik]
drei Euro würde ich gerne machen
toll
toll ich lass mich hier immer ich lass
mich hier ich kann nicht wahrnehmen 3
Euro
bezahlen aber guck mal da hinten ist
auch der Preis 14.99
[Musik]
Weg nichts kommt in die Kasse das ist
Flohmarkt Flohmärkte haben wirklich
diesen abenteuerwald man weiß nie was
ein erwartet man ist wie auf einer
Schnitzeljagd und Stadt nach Hinweisen
schaut man nach dem besten Schnäppchen
die man kriegen kann und diese ganzen
Menschen zu sehen die sich an Dinge von
dir interessieren den du schon so lange
keine Aufmerksamkeit mehr gegeben hast
das hat so eine ganz eigene Magie
moin hier sind danke danke
dann macht das alles so hier wieder
gleich Spaß
es ist 12 Uhr 23 Uhr und wir sind fast
ausverkauft also naja
fast bisschen gibt's noch was aber
wirklich nur noch ein bisschen ich habe
so viel an diesem Tag gelernt zum
Beispiel dass man bei den Verkäufern mit
ein paar Sympathie Punkten einen
besseren Preis bekommen
kein Problem das verkaufen wir dir
Naomi geht Weg
zum Dritten verkauft eine junge Lady für
1 €
und wie viel ich insgesamt in einem
Flohmarkt verdient habe das erfahren wir
jetzt und habt ihr es gesehen perfekt
dann äh bis zum nächsten mal ne also wir
gehen erstmal mit einem Minus rein wenn
die Standmiete kostet 40 €, das fand ich
schon sehr teuer dafür bekommt man aber
einen Tisch und einen regen Sonnenschutz
es war sehr Unternehmen dort aber es gab
keine Toiletten das gibt es bestimmt
besser an manchen anderen Stellen am
Abend vorher wäre dieses flohmarkt-ding
vielleicht schon geplatzt bzw sehr
kompliziert geworden denn ich habe mich
nicht um Kleingeld gekümmert ich weiß
dass man mittlerweile auf dem Flohmarkt
auch mit PayPal zahlen kann ich mag es
jetzt aber nicht meine PayPal E-Mail
abzugeben ist einfach aus Gründen dass
ich mal wann aus dem Internet bin und
manchmal bin ich dann vorsichtiger als
andere vielleicht aber ich habe dann
Timo und mein Sparschwein aufgemacht und
das hat mir wirklich den Arsch gerettet
und zwar habe ich da 50 Cent Stücke im
Wert von 30 € rausbekommen 1 € Stücke im
Wert von 26 € und 2 € Stücke in Wert von
12 € und wie ihr seht bin ich dadurch
erstmal 108 € im Minus das fängt doch
schon mal fantastisch an jetzt machen
wir den Mister krabs und zehn die
Monaten
gemacht ne
kein Geld gibt's auch noch 50 100
150 200 250 3
und wenn ich jetzt daran denke dass ich
so oft sehr gute Sachen von mir unten
bei meinem Nachbarn hingestellt habe
also wir haben da so ein Brett und da
können wir einfach Sachen hinstellen die
noch gut sind und die man verschenken
möchte dass man sehr gute Sachen immer
ich hätte Geld daraus machen können 360
[Musik]
460 470 480 4
€. oh und dann noch das Kleingeld
wir haben ja noch die 108 Euro - Mist
ich wurde gerade ein bisschen Geld geil
jetzt erzähl mir mal Münzen ne 10 15 25
30 noch mal drei Euro
533 €
- 108 sind immer noch
425 Euro und da freue ich mich so denn
das war alles Zeug was bei mir im
Schrank war und ich habe sogar noch
teilweise viel zu günstig verkauft das
heißt man kann wahrscheinlich noch viel
mehr machen ja ein Flohmarkt ist
anstrengend aber er macht auch wirklich
Spaß man tritt mit Menschen in Kontakt
man hat ein paar gute Unterhaltungen und
man wertschätzt die Dinge die man mal
besessen hat für Kleidung für kleine
Gegenstände und fährt volle
Sammlerstücke lohnt es sich wirklich für
die größeren elektronischen Gegenstände
die wir loswerden wollen werde ich auf
Online Portale zurückgreifen da wollte
ich jetzt nicht mit meinem großen
Fernseher stehen und den verkaufen habt
der zu gut ist um in euren Schubladen zu
verändern gebt den zweite Chance
verdient
Grüße an alle Fans von vaness